- Vous avez employé vous-même
dans votre intervention à
des mots très durs. On les a
déjà capotés n'était pas par
qui se faisait. Et donc, mais
c'était prévisible que la Russie
allait mettre son veto sur une
résolution qu'elle est
- Je ne suis pas surpris.
l'existence d'un veto pour la
Russie. On n'est pas surpr
Mais on voit des sanctions
Europe et avec l'OTAN etc. Je
crois qu'on a vu une s
de l'alliance des pays qui sont
clairement contre l'activité de
Monsie
des crimes de guerre qui existe
l'arrêté. C'est contre la loi
internationale. Vous avez dit
que j'étais des montures, on n'a
pas le choix. Les modèles à
diplomatie ne sont pas
suffisants pour vraiment
reconnaître que de tuer les
enfants et attaquer des
appartements « l'existence de
tout un peuple et une
population, de toute
nationalités, ni même État ukra,
c'est un aspect de la penséee ea
tête de Monsieur Poutine.OnOnOnt
comprendre qu'il y a des
conséquences pour les activités,
pour les efforts qu'elle vient
de faire. Il leur a une période
très difficile pour la
population ukrainienne. On ne
peut pas prédire ce qui va
arriver mais c'est vrai que le
situation.
- Parce qu'on peut se titititité
Poutine au cours de toute cette
semaine. Les E
présent de sonner l'alarme. Mais
on disait nodededededededededede
dollars dans tous les pays. On a
envi
Pourtant, à Kiev, c'est Zelensky
quoioioioioioioioioir dans une
Qu'est-ce que vous ressenteze e?
l'dictateur. On doit reconnaître
l'intégrité territoriale de la
c'est important, c'est tri
que nous voyons avec les pertes
de vie et avec eux tou
arrive, mais cela
dire que l'on garde le temps
pour
qui compte. C'est l'existence
poququququququququququi compte.s
puisque l'Ukraine n'est pasmbmbe
appelle la militaire un coup
d'état. Elle était auxles pouvol
est dit venait à Minsk pour
négocier mais capituler avant.
Qu'est-ce qu'on répond?
- Il peut dire toutes sortes d
choses Monsieur Poutine. C
un propagandiste de première
taille. Nous devons to
appuyer le gouvernement de
l'Ukraine, l'effort de l'armée
ukrainienne
ukrainienne. Il faut continuer
avec les
nous sommes en faveur des
sanctions pour les systèmes
sysysysysysysysysysysysystèmesne
solidaire. Le gouvernement aarat
d'accord avec nous. On vadididi.
C'est un pouvoir nucléaire ave
la guerre. Ce n'est pas chaque
jour qu'on va faire une tell
décision. Sans vraiment penser
aux conséquences. C'est ce
fait l'OTAN et nous avons
continue de le faire. C'est ce
qui va arriver mon va
sur la voie non seulement de la
communs.
- Est-ce que vous pensez que
Poutin
l'OTAN et permettre aux États-
Unis d'assumer à nouveau une
sorte de leadership? Mais la
t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-ce
un signal que l'on craint n n ne
au-delà de l'Ukraine et qu'il
- Il y a deux voisins qui sont
la Géorgie et les voisins de las
attaquer? Est-ce qu'elle valala?
Monsieur Poutine a parlé d'un
empire russe. Il veut retour
aux frontières du passé. C'est
le langage de di
utilise les mêmes phrases
exactement. Les mémés idées de
L'Expansion. Elle parle...
qu'est-ce qu'il pense? On ne
peut pas répondre? Il faut
commencer avec des sanctions.ree
les pourparlers pour las's's's't
interrompue. Il y a beaucoup dee
de l'impact dans l'espoir. Il ye
cela papyrus qui pourraitiririr.
- Vous aurez des problèmes avece
capitales qui sont e
engendre ce soir.
passé. C'est presque une
nouvelle gue
- C'est une guerre en Ukraine.
- En ce moment mais après?
-
froide.
- Il veut un nouvel ordre
. . . . . . . . . . . . . . . .e
exercé une telle agressionououos
choses qu'il a inventées, il
invente tous les jours, ce n'est
pas la langue de la démocratie.
Ce n'est pas le langage desonon.
Cela va exiger une réponse
différen
les pa
ordr
respect pour la personnalité
humaine. Et naturellement, on
c'est Monsieur Poutine qui est u
nez certain sent de consensusitt
les doit comprendre qu'il aura
des conséquences. Nous allonsmen
l'importance de la justice pou
la population ukrainienne. Etuse
solidarité important
pays, qui ce soir va trouver une
situation diffic
- Le Canada va ouvrir ses portes
aux réfugiés ukrainiens.
- Oui. Naturellement nous allons
accepter des réfugiés. C'est ce
que le Canada P. C'est le Canada
les réfugiés et des émigrants de
faire. On va le faire d'une
façon réglée avec nos
- Merci beaucoup de nous avoir